hello and welcome to the shaky science
show in this video we'll look at a
merman and it's linked with fertility
and alternative arts say pretty much
this video will focus on this recent
sale reports paper that is NAD+
repletion rescues female fertility
during reproductive aging and so this
was a really interesting paper that came
out only a couple of weeks ago and it
was a huge collaboration of lots of
different labs
some of which I've named her but
honestly though I've topped and held the
list of authors a lot of life went into
this study and so I'll pretty much
discuss some of the main findings from
this paper in this video but before
jumping straight into the paper there's
quite a few terminology we need to get
our heads around first so the first of
which is art and so art stands for
assisted reproductive technologies and
say these are technologies that are
currently used for people who suffer
with infertility to enable them to have
children and so the problem of these
technologies such as in featuring
fertilization is that they are quite
limiting and they have health concerns
related to them as well so also
therefore expensive therefore in face of
technologies as I said there could be
associated health risks and there's also
limited success rates and given that
it's quite expensive you can see you
need the costs really increasing but you
know why is the reproductive decline in
the first place why do people need to
use these assisted reproductive
technologies well in female mammals
reproductive aging is an irreversible
process and the main reason for this is
considered to be due to a decline in
oversights quality that occurs as you
age and this is therefore rate limiting
for human fertility so before I go any
further what actually is an insight well
an insight is both simple way to think
about it is an immature egg so if I draw
some insights here we can see that it
looks like pretty much like a cell it's
got a nucleus it's got a cytoplasm
escort's plasma membrane and it's
surrounded by what is referred to as the
corona radiata didn't worry too much
about where that is
what happens is these it was like they
do mature I made mature into eggs and
then the egg is fertilized by sperm Ania
you know what happens you get side gates
and then an early embryo and so the
quality of these oversights decline as
you age in females so well why do they
they age why does the quality decrease
well if you notice a lot of the
phenotypes you can see that they're
associated with the different hallmarks
of aging so older sites show you genomic
instability reduced mitochondrial
bioenergetics and also they show
compromised cell division which is
really important for early embryonic
development but one of the main reasons
why our sites are so accessible to aging
is that the insights of deposited in the
ovary during a mutual development so at
a very early stage of life right and
they aren't replenished by self
populating population of cells stem
cells basically like you getting skin so
once you've got this finite population
of your sites you know that's pretty
much it there until they're used what is
that's what we currently think about it
was like development and so maybe it's
not that surprising then that as a
recites are susceptible to the aging
process and we need to have division in
this early stage of embryonic
development that there is infertility
associated with older and aged Oh sites
and you really need a good starting your
sites for embryonic development since is
the building block for the rest of the
embryo and processes like in vitro
fertilization they don't actually
improve the quality they just train
enhance the fertilization process so how
can you enhance the quality of other
sites well that's what this study kind
of looks at and the error they focus on
is the cofactor nad which stands for
nicotinamide adenine dinucleotide
have a video where I go into more detail
about nad but it is a key factor and
it's one of the most abundant molecules
in the human body and there are kind of
two main functions
of NAD+ that can be categorized into its
role as a redox cofactor and also as a
substrate for nad plus consuming enzymes
and these include pretty in such as
sirtuins
or statins it's not really talked with
the correct way to say that is so why
did the authors decide to look at nad
Plus levels well firstly nad plus levels
are known to decline as we age and as I
mentioned nad plus is a redox cofactor
and it's involved in energy and
metabolism and recites and fertility and
fire citation is an energetically
demanding process with a lot of rapid
grades so you can see the connection
between the two and so what they did was
they firstly they they measured the
levels of NADH which is the reduced form
of nad plus because nad plus is really
hard to measure accurately and also the
phosphorylated form of any D which is
NADPH and they did this from extracted
Mitchell herbicides and they did this in
young mice say around four to five weeks
olds Oh twice around twelve months and
then all the mice that had been treated
with an ax men for four weeks so an ax
men is nicotinamide smonny nucleotides
and it's a precursor for an eighty plus
and so I was talking about n MN a lot
before but just to refresh NM n is
converted into nad plus I'm so the
rationale for the female mice taking n
MN is to enhance the nad Plus levels to
prevent the age associated decline in
the nad levels so if we take a look at
some of their results from the study we
can see that when the older female mice
were given n MN you can see that the
decline in nad pH levels and nad levels
was actually reduced so you can see it
kind of matches the levels seen in the
young mice but does actually make a
difference to the other side quality and
so this is the next thing that the paper
goes on to you and so the assess the
breeding performance or
the autumn eyes who have been taking any
men by looking at the pregnancy the
number of live births the litter size
and also this mental assembly which is
the structure of the spindles and the
chromosome alignment which is in
critical process in cell division so if
you don't know where spindles are
they're kind of like fibery things that
attach to the chromosomes that look like
this if you've seen images or cells
dividing so it does nmn it hunts the
other sites quality so let us take a
look at some of their data so what we
can see in these figures here is that
taking nmn and increase the number of
live births and also the number of pups
in the listener as well and
interestingly you can see that 0.5 grams
per liter of nmn enhanced oversight
quality but it also enhanced the ear
sight quality more than taking 2 grams
per liter in the mice which was a really
interesting finding that the Hyades
actually wasn't as good as the lower
days with an ax men and so MMN as a
breakdown product which is nicotinamide
n a.m. and so nicotinamide is thought to
inhibit search wins so that is one
explanation the authors gave for why it
was less effective than the lower dose
but I think the the key point which the
authors do enforce is that you know this
is really new and exciting research but
at the moment taking supplements such as
elements to enhance your nad levels
shouldn't be taken by women wishing to
become pregnant until there have been
further studies done to test this and
humans you know at the moment has just
been done in mice and the mechanism
behind it isn't fully understood yet so
to recap what we've discussed so far
we've seen that this paper has shown
that declining levels of NADH is
associated with the asite this function
during reproductive aging and that this
oversight quality and fertility could be
restored when the autumn eyes were
treated with an ax men and well they
also go on to show in this paper is that
if you also supplement
the embryo media so this is post
fertilization with nmn it's also
improved the development of the early
embryos and so this could be a kind of
non-invasive strategy to enhance IVF but
again this is something that has been
done in mice and shouldn't you know it
needs to give me clinical trials and
tested in humans before anyone considers
taking animal as a supplement for this
purpose and the last thing they tried to
look more into the mechanism behind why
any men could enhance the other side
quality and so they showed that sir to a
certain labor expression mimics some of
the benefits of taking in a man but they
they think it's unlikely to mediate the
full of X so the precise mechanism
through which increased NADH levels
increase the fitness of the euro sites
it's not entirely clear yet however
based on the research their group
generally thinks that it could be
related to the energetic role of NAD+
however one aspect that wasn't discussed
in the paper which you know I'm going to
say that I am not an expert in any
particular way is the epigenetics and so
I actually rates an essay on the art of
genetic imprinting the pun art being
assisted reproductive technologies where
I talked all about how methylation and
how during early embryonic development
there's a whole change and modifications
are carrying in the epigenome and this
is really important for early
development and whilst that was mainly
focusing on methylation um NAD+ is
linked with certain activity in
husband's are the earth leases and you
have his theme theses Latian and is that
involved in regulating the oocyte
growing from development I don't really
know I just think that's another
interesting area and also going to David
Sinclair's book life span where he talks
about his information theory of aging
and linking that to epigenetics there
could be something in aging epigenetics
ID and it was like quality but who knows
like I said I'm one expert I just think
this papers really cool and you know if
this could help to prevent infertility
problems in a non-invasive way I think
it's very exciting
yeah we'll see what happens in the
future so as always thanks for listening